in the last few minutes confirmation  that the Six Nations match in Rome  between England and Italy on March the  14th along with the equivalent matches  for the Under 20's and the women's team  all postponed because of the corona  virus England are playing Wales in the  Six Nations art Wiccan this Saturday  winged Antony Watson in your picture  here as in for Jonathan Joseph while  flanker Mark Wilson replaces the injured  Sam on Dale and for Wales  here's Liam Williams who with Josh de  bebé returns to the starting lineup and  Dan bigger is fit to start at fly-half  despite injuring his knee in their last  game against France